[Musique]
c'est le poisson bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à téléphiles 78
vous êtes là en tant que commissaire
d'une exposition qui démarre tout juste
à versailles au musée lambinet cette
exposition s'appelle les amazones de la
révolution et dieu jusqu'au 19 février
absolument absolument ensuite kit vous
dans la vie je suis professeur à
l'université de paris 8 en histoire
culturelle donc je tiens à la fois sur
les représentations de la société dans
la culture et sur la façon dont la
culture modifie la façon dont la société
se conçoit alors attendez de sellières
croire et ça ça veut dire que l'art
n'est pas simplement le reflet de la
société de son temps il est aussi
capable de modifier les mentalités les
sensibles impact ces motions little
assurent les la société de son temps
d'accord évidemment également regarde la
mémoire qu'elle nous laisse d'accord
donc ça c'est ce que vous enseignez à la
femme absolument voilà ensuite vous êtes
aussi mon ce n'est pas votre première
exposition vous en avez commises
d'autres mais je récidive de récidive et
j'en ai fait notamment une sur la
question des imaginaires culturel de la
révolution française aujourd'hui dans
les arts dans les médias dans les
cultures populaires dans la publicité au
musée de la révolution française en 2012
ce musée est à vizille côté de grenoble
a été inaugurée peu de temps avant le
bicentenaire de la révolution
pour pouvoir préparer les événements
commémoratifs d'accord donc la voulons
vous avez montré finalement tout ce qui
restait de la dde de la révolution
aujourd'hui dans l'art d'aujourd'hui les
vestiges oui j'ai monté non j'ai montré
les mythologies entretenu autour de la
révolution française de nos jours donc
la façon dont la mémoire des événements
et transforme se détournent parfois même
et subvertit par des artistes qui peut
tenir un discours rétrospective sur les
faits et donc tout ça énerve la
conscience qu'on peut avoir de
l'histoire y compris dans des formes
totalement inattendus tels que la
publicité les médias la caricature
politique c'est rigolo et alors vous me
disiez que cette représentation de la
révolution avait été aussi utilisés à
l'étranger absolument c'était clair vous
par exemple alors au japon en
particulier au japon il ya un manga qui
publié en 1973 la rose de versailles et
qui a ensuite entraîné une multitude de
produits dérivés des comédies musicales
jouées depuis une vingtaine d'années
dans le monde entier plusieurs films
dont un film de jacques demy quand même
si lady oscar ça s'est inspiré ou de
cette fausse héroïne fictionnel qui
était une qui était considéré comme la
la garde personnelle de marie-antoinette
passer ensuite à la révolution d'accord
donc ça c'était ça c'est pour le japon
dont le japon aux états-unis alors bien
avant le film de sofia coppola sur la
reine marie antoinette en 2006 on a tout
un imaginaire extrêmement populaire d'un
côté avec parfois des choses de très
mauvais goût comme des petites figurines
pour enfants avec une marie antoinette
des kpi table un nigaud avec également
des guillotines en pièces détachées à
monter soi-même en modélisme avec
également des tas de publicité toutes
plus délirantes les unes que les autres
qui entretiennent en particulier des
idées fausses notamment le fameux la
fameuse phrase de marie antoinette sur
les brioches ils n'ont plus de pain
qu'on leur donne et brioches qui était
amplifiée répercuter est très ouverte et
qui plaît beaucoup puisque ça permet
d'entretenir cette haine démarrera
ruscha les gars n et nostalgie
d'ailleurs mélange ambiguë en tout cas
dans les imaginaires que j'avais
rencontré d'accord cette exposition donc
là vous êtes commissaire donc de cette
exposition pour la deuxième fois c'est
donc au musée lambinet c'est par hasard
le musée lambinet puisqu'il existe déjà
le fonds va t'elle qui est en permanence
le vide est nominé oui constitue le plus
gros fonds consacrés à charlotte corday
du monde je crois qu'on peut le dire
d'ailleurs grâce à un effet charles
va-t-elle collectionneurs de premier
plan figure importante du milieu
versaillais qui a à peu près acquis tout
ce qui circulait à l'époque sur le sujet
et qui a eu aussi la chance de pouvoir
avoir des témoignages directs de gens
qui étaient encore vivants et qui avait
été contemporain des faits donc il a
collecté une mémoire à l'être ce
pectives de première main des événements
et publié notamment un ouvrage tout à
fait important sur sur 7 sur cette
figure est donc à partir de cette
matrice l'idée de l'exposition était de
rendre justice un certain nombre de
figures féminines pour la plupart
oublier contrairement à charlo de cold
kordek honte charlotte corday et
entretenus à la fois par la mémoire
contre révolutionnaires qui s'en est
emparé en partie malgré elle est
également par la mémoire républicaine
qui lui a consacré une légende noire et
qui en fait une figure de l'ennemi
public numéro un donc elle a gardé
évidemment une certaine notoriété auprès
du grand public est rarement à beaucoup
d'autres voilà un gadget exposition rend
justice justement elles sont là dans
cette exposition elles sont 4 1 alors
vous les avez choisi parce qu'il n'y en
avait que 4 ou vous avez opéré une
sélection drastique alors le choix était
difficile il y en a beaucoup en fait en
réalité il ya plus de 60 femmes soldats
pendant la révolution française il ya
des dizaines de salles honneur il ya et
c'est génial ça veut dire des personnes
qui tiennent salon oui c'est des femmes
qui réunissent autour d'elle une
communauté choisi de scientifiques
d'hommes de lettres d'hommes politiques
et qui échange d'un certain nombre
d'idées sur la société de leur temps
donc elles ont un rôle très actif dans
la construction d'une opinion publique
oui mais je dirais que ça c'est plutôt
une tradition qui est née sous l'ancien
régime ce qui est nouveau sous la
révolution française c'est qu'elles vont
venir témoigner à la tribune qu elles
vont participer aux assemblées
populaires qu'elles vont avoir un rôle
assez active dans les clubs patriotique
là on estime à entre 20 et 30 % de
femmes dans ces fameuses sociétés
patriotiques et elles vont exprimer un
certain nombre d'idées notamment sur le
rapport des femmes aux événements et
l'implication des femmes dans l'espace
public d'accord alors quand on se rend à
cette exposition on peut acquérir
cet objet qui n'est pas vraiment un
catalogue qui est plus un livre qui
reprend très en détail la vie de ces
quatre amazon et qui donne une vision
très très large en fait de toute cette
époque et qui est juste passionnant est
bon on va revenir un peu ce ces quatre
femmes alors déjà
donc la plus connue charlotte corday eux
d'où venait-elle cette fameuse charlotte
qui assassine et mara voilà alors
charlotte corday et de petite
aristocratie normande elle a été élevée
chez les soeurs allait d'ailleurs au
moment de la révolution française on l'a
on la sort de son de son couvent oui à
ses destinées à 12 ans il se destiner
aux ordres toutes à l'arrêt c'est
contrairement à ce que la légende
républicaine a répercuté ensuite c'est
une femme relativement instruite killy
qui se documente sur la société soupe de
son temps et qui finalement va être un
peu saisis par les événements et
considérer qu elle a une mission à
remplir que l'assassinât de marat est un
acte ii
ne devra rack de bravoure est un devoir
finalement qui permettrait dit elle dans
notariat sa lettre à son père est
également son procès face à fouquier
tinville qu'ils aient une façon de
d'épargné des milliers de vies humaines
oui est ce que marc a été pour l un des
pires sanguinaire et elle pensait qu en
le tuant ça ça ça permettrait de limiter
les effusions de sang voilà elle pensait
pas le pacte de terre terroriste aussi
moderne du terme donc un meurtre
politique pouvoir effectivement enrayer
le dispositif delà de la terreur d'acorn
auquel ben finalement
guillotine et voilà la peña là après on
a aussi aux liens de gauche alors olympe
de gouges est intéressante parce que
c'est une femme qui deux siècles avant
les combats féministes de notre temps
ils sont loin d'être gagnée comme on le
sait a fait là à mis en évidence
notamment le fait que la déclaration des
droits de l'homme jouait sur une
confusion entre hommes au sens masculin
et on au sens humain humanitaire est
très moderne les temps modernes et l
détricote complètement le droit
révolutionnaire pour montrer que les
flat les femmes sont une nouvelle fois
occulter dans l'histoire et qu'elles ont
un rang à tenir dans la sphère publique
mais son action ne se limite pas là
puisqu'elle est également
du côté de la cause des comme on
disait à l'époque mais les
abolitionnistes elle refuse l'esclavagé
elle refuse la traite coloniale ce qui
lui vaut d'ailleurs des menaces de mort
de la part cabale des colons voilà elle
met en oeuvre une grande pièce de
théâtre sur l'esclavagé des est
ce qu'il est
après on va parler aussi de manon roland
roland est une figure qui a été
injustement réduite à son rôle de
conseillère de son mari ministre de
l'intérieur de la révolution qui est
également une grande salonnière au sens
où on en parlait tout à l'heure qui est
une figure intellectuelle au sens
moderne du terme de figure d'instruction
une femme qui très rapidement met en
garde contre le risque d' emballement du
processus révolutionnaire contre
les exactions d'un peuple livré à lui
même qui est très proche également de la
gironde c'est l'égérie des jouets du
monde est ce qu'on peut dire sur les
plus pacifiques alors ça se pose pas
tout à fait en ces termes mais disons
qu'ils sont pour une vision peut-être
plus modéré moins radicale à la fois de
l'organisation politique de l'état
nation est également de la société du
temps et en tous cas bien clairement
hostiles au régime de la terreur dans
quel ordre pour finir nous avons
théroigne de méricourt
quel drôle de nom théroigne de méricourt
il t'a fait intéressant donc qui nous
vient de belgique qui était une de liège
en particulier est une
fermière régine qui va arriver à paris
au début de la révolution française qui
aurait dit on mais c'est pas tout à fait
avéré participer à la marche des femmes
salaire juste à m'en excuser moi je vous
coupe la marche des femmes se sont
toutes une sorte d'armé qui sait
composer un peu de façon instantanée de
des femmes de paris qui sont montés à
versailles pour
réclamer le roi c'est ça qui reviennent
à paris c'est ça l'histoire et à leurs
armes et c'est peut-être un grand mot
mais c'est une maillot s'était armé oui
alors elles avaient des armes à la non
des pics fait donc ça on voit aussi très
bien dans l'exposition il ya plusieurs
salles il ya notamment une salle
de d'art contemporain voilà avec la
peintre zucca et aussi il y as may du
mou oui le peintre du moussa ce sont
deux contemporains qui nous montre une
représentation actuelle de la révolution
et il ya un autre truc que j'ai oublié
de vous dire de vous demander pardon
c'est qu'on voit qu'il ya deux clans
dans ces familles à les tricoteuses et
les merveilleuses qui sont représentés
aussi enfin on voit bien ça dans l'expo
c'est quoi les tricoteuses alors oui
l'idée de l'exposition était de montrer
non seulement des figures individuelle
mais également des figures plus
collective les tricoteuses sont ces
femmes qui au début des événements ont
assisté aux délibérations des
différentes assemblées ont participé au
club patriotiques ont participé à la vie
des sections dit-on en tricotant un
écoutant les délibérations plus donc on
voit bien le double sens de cette
métaphore le tricot c'est quand même
associé à voilà une stéréo type de
l'aménageur et la sphère domestique
rendue publique par cette présence aux
assemblées et puis rapidement cette
image des tricoteuses va se retourner en
une figure beaucoup plus négative où on
les considère comme des harpies solution
à n'en plus que ça des délais chesea de
guillotine dit on à l'époque des à sa
fille de femmes qui voilà qui se
complaisent à venir assister aux
exécutants blick en comptant les têtes
qui tombent avec leurs mailles et donc
il ya tout un imaginaire extrêmement
macabre se répercute d'ailleurs jusque
dans le cinéma contemporain qu'on
retrouve dans le cinéma d'histoire
aujourd'hui face à un changé donc on
voit la longévité de ces stéréotypes et
face à elle par les merveilleuses qui
font partie d'une jeunesse un peu doré
qui s'est un peu plus tard qu'ils sont
un peu plus décontracté par rapport à
tous ces drames et qui se moque un peu
de la terreur bon pour en savoir plus il
faut absolument aller voir cette
expression system en riche que voilà et
juste pour terminer finalement ces
femmes qui ont participé à la révolution
qui ont donné leur vie
alors on leur dit
merci quand elles font quand elles font
le l'acte une fois qu'elles veulent
continuer à faire partie de la vie
politique on leur dit manon finalement
vous êtes comportés comme des hommes
donc restez chez vous c'est un peu ça
l'idée voilà alors ça ça peut l'ironie
de l'histoire c'est effectivement ces
femmes ces fameuses amazones de la
mission française auquel le livre en
justice sont des femmes qui ont
revendiqué une égalité de traitement
avec les hommes dix ans si on actions
que monter à la guillotine on doit
pouvoir monter également à la tribune et
qui revendique notamment c'est le cap
théroigne de méricourt en particulier
l'utilisation de la violence comme un
outil politique pour l'histoire cette
violence qu'elles revendiquent eux se
retourne ensuite contre elle puisqu' on
les rend responsables d'une
radicalisation des événements donc c'est
faites ce que je dis mais pas ce que je
fasse pas ce que je dis mais pas ce que
je fais à face est complètement injuste
cette histoire oui bah c'est là qu'on
voit que la révolution française n'a pas
de vrai très efficacement à la coke et à
écouter il ya plein de choses à dire
encore bravo pour cette magnifique expo
on va tous aller voir parce que c'est
très riche très instructif
pour voir
[Musique]